we are no longer acquainted with death I
don't know who you are we don't see
death we're not around death very much
anymore and so whenever someone dies we
view that as an accident we view that as
something preventable there are all
sorts of Genius zillionaires in Silicon
Valley who are investing oodles and
oodles of money to cure death just like
the Pharaohs of old they view death as
some evil awful thing an obstacle to be
overcome no one here Gets Out Alive okay
and in a way while death is a curse for
the Disobedience of our first parents in
the Garden of Eden it it's also a way
out because you don't want to live
forever in a fallen world that would be
a terribly painful experience and we do
have the opportunity to live forever but
it's not in the way that the that
liberal utopians think it is